épouvantable bain de sang à sarajevo un
obus a explosé sur un marché à une heure
de grande écoute plus de 60 morts nous
retrouvons en direct notre envoyé
spécial à sarajevo à rennes l'ancien
parlement de bretagne a été ravagé par
un incendie la nuit dernière
un sinistre qui pourrait être une
conséquence de la manifestation des
marins pêcheurs
ce parlement qui abritait entre autres
les dossiers du juge van holsbeeck était
l'un des joyaux du patrimoine français
invités de ce journal en direct de
rennes le maire de la ville edmond hervé
qui protestent contre l'inefficacité du
service d'ordre hier alors que charles
pasqua met en cause l' irresponsabilité
de certains élus malgré les nouvelles
mesures annoncées en leur faveur hier à
rennes les marins pêcheurs ne semble pas
décidé à mettre fin à leur mouvement
dernier titre c'est aujourd'hui que
prend effet la prive de 5000 francs pour
l'achat d'une voiture neuve en échange
d'un véhicule de plus de dix ans madame
monsieur bonsoir c'est l' escalade de
l'horreur à sarajevo un obus de fort
calibre est tombée ce matin sur le
principal marché de cette ville à une
heure de grande affluence
le dernier bilan fait état de 61 morts
et de 142 blessés
françoise joly
pour lui il est déjà trop tard l'urgence
c'est d'évacuer ce qu'ils vivent encore
au milieu de ces et taille de ces corps
déchiquetés un seul mot catastrophe
mais paris
et pas le temps d'improviser des
civières les blessés plus de 200
personnes sont transportées avec les
moyens du bord chargés à l'arrière de
camions ou dans des coffres de voiture
tous sont des civils
beaucoup des personnes âgées jamais le
plus grand marché de sarajevo n'avait
été bombardés protéger disait ton par
des immeubles de plusieurs étages
il a donc fallu viser très précisément
ce matin un seul au but pour un carnage
et la mort en sueur à l'hôpital que ces
veaux de sarajevo le service d'urgence
et déborde et les derniers blessés sont
étendus dans les couloirs les entrées
les morts plus de 60 sont transportés
pour la plupart à la morgue de l'hôpital
une équipe d'experts des casques bleus
est immédiatement envoyée sur les lieux
du bombardement pour tenter de
déterminer l'origine de l'eau du qui a
frappé le marché nord nord-est 10e
casques bleus mais si les conclusions
définitives de la forpronu ne sont
connus que demain pour les autorités
bosniaques pas de doute le projectile
provient des positions serbes
certaines sont postés précisément au
nord-est de sarajevo
radovan karadzic le leader serbe
bosniaque a lui accusé les musulmans de
bosnie d'avoir eux-mêmes bombardé le
marché pour torpiller les prochaines
négociations de paix à genève les hier
c'est le chef de la forpronu lui même le
général michael rose qui avait tenu les
serbes responsable de la mort de neuf
civils dans la banlieue de sarajevo
c'est de loin le massacre le plus
meurtrier depuis le début du siège de la
capitale bosniaque id la de cela
maintenant 22 mois un siège au cours
duquel près de 10000 habitants de
sarajevo ou perdu la vie nous retrouvons
directe de cette ville jean-jacques le
garrec bonsoir jean jacques merci d'être
avec nous quel est ce soir
pourrait-on dire l'état d'esprit des
habitants de sarajevo c'est évidemment
un choc terrible c'est l'attentât et
massacres
plus grave depuis le début de cette
guerre tous les gens qui vivent à
sarajevo et qui sont ici en permanence
ne s'habitue jamais à cette accumulation
d'horreur qui nous revient tous les
jours
là on a atteint point d'horreur à ces
intolérables et beaucoup de photographes
ce matin hésité à faire des photos et
ont mis longtemps avant de reprendre
leur métier car tout le monde ici a été
choquée arrêter de travailler arrêté de
de pouvoir vivre dans cette ville
françoise joly le dise il ya un instant
chacun bien sûr chaque communauté chaque
camp se rejette la responsabilité de
cette épouvantable au massacre
est-ce que vous avez des précisions sur
l'origine de cette polémique est ici
presque aussi insoutenable que les
bonzes elle-même depuis 22 mois cette
ville est bombardé il y à des snipers
des tireurs embusqués il y à des obus
qui tombent tous les jours et c'est vrai
qu'à chaque fois qu'un obus et très
meurtrier il ya une analyse de cratères
qui est fait par la forpronu il ya un
long délai avant de pouvoir réellement
dire d'où vient l'eau bue cette
polémique est ici presque aussi
insoutenable que les obus au même il
faut dire que la provocation peut venir
des deux côtés mais on ne peut pas
s'enfermer en permanence dans ce genre
de débat les populations et s'ils
refusent complètement devoir à la fois
l'horreur et d'imaginer une horreur
encore plus grande en voyant les baux de
l'iso but venir de leur propre côté la
polémique est toujours la même et le
président yves bigot riche disait cet
après midi dans une conférence de presse
que si un jour il était assassiné
eh ben les adversaires prétendrait qu'il
s'est lui-même suicidé hier après le
bombardement de l'ancien village
olympique qui avait tué huit personnes
dont deux enfants l'anc est conduite par
les casques bleus sur place avait conclu
avec certitude à la culpabilité des
forces serbes de bosnie et le nouveau
patron de la forpronu le général
britannique michael rose avait affirmé
qu'il fallait je le cite que les
responsables soient confrontés à leurs
actions criminelles alors jean jacques
est ce que les casques bleus vont selon
vous réagir plus fort et où est-ce qu'on
envisage sérieusement ses frappes
aériennes sur place les casques bleus
sur le terrain sont un peu pris en porte
à faux entre cette horreur
de plus en plus gras de cette folie
meurtrière qui entoure la population et
les populations de plus en plus
exaspérés par leur attitude non pas leur
attitude en tant que casque bleu mais
l'attitude de la communauté
internationale qui n'a
vient pas concernant la seule réaction
possible pour les mortiers et les canons
qui tire sur sa rive où il n'y a que
l'intervention aérienne
or pour l'intervention aérienne
aujourd'hui la seule décision qui peut
être prise sur les territoires de
l'ex-yougoslavie leçon par yasushi
akashi qui le représentant spécial de
boutros boutros ghali le secrétaire
général de l'onu et qui est en poste à
zagreb il ne peut en décider qu'en cas
d'agression caractérisée contre les
casques bleus donc à sarajevo quand des
obus tombent
personne ne peut décider de réagir et
d'interdire ce genre de bombardements
merci beaucoup j'aurais pu garer que je
rappelle que vous êtes pour france 2
notre envoyé spécial dans cette ville de
sarajevo
via un communiqué du quai d'orsay la
france a vigoureusement condamné ce
nouveau massacre de sarajevo exprimant
je cite son horreur et son indignation
devant ces actes odieux
le nouveau secrétaire d'état américain à
la défense a de nouveau menacé les
belligérants de frappes aériennes par
les avions de l'otan rappelant que le
président clinton avait promis que les
états unis ne permettrait pas que ça
riez vous soit étranglée en france c'est
la consternation à rennes après l
incendie qui a ravagé la nuit dernière
l'ancien parlement de bretagne l'un des
joyaux du patrimoine français un
incendie qui pourrait avoir été
provoquée par l'une des nombreuses
fusées de détresse lancés par les
manifestants dans l'après midi
un sinistre qui risque également d'avoir
des conséquences politico judiciaire car
ce bâtiment abritait le bureau mais
aussi des dossiers et sur tous les
dossiers du juge van ruymbeke
reportage de nos correspondants jacques
debout jambes ou laine
le feu implacable il n'aura fallu que
quelques heures pour qu'il détruise aux
deux tiers
un bâtiment qui a traversé plus de trois
sièges du parlement de bretagne les 120
pompiers présents ne pourront sauver que
le premier étage et le rez de chaussée
personne ne peut pour leur expliquer les
causes du sinistre
mais beaucoup pensent à la violente
manifestation de la journée
des témoins ont vu des fusées de
détresse touché le bâtiment effet dès 4h
et juste rossier
il y avait tous les lacrymo dans la rue
il ya une bombe
les jeunes rouge japonaise
jusque là
voilà l'endroit
derrière leur apple a cramé cinq minutes
quoi au matin une scène de désolation
s'offre aux yeux des rennais a couru en
mars toute la journée on se presse pour
voir les dégâts
l'émotion est vive ce matin moi j'ai
pleuré parce que c'est vraiment je peux
pas je peux pas y croire c'est on a
l'impression que c'est un cauchemar de
voir la bretagne
ac c'est une grande hésitation
moi je suis très attristé a raconté sa
mission d'en parler on est on est très
bouleversée franchement le parlement de
bretagne abrite la cour d'appel de
rennes
l' incendie va donc perturber le
fonctionnement de la justice des
dossiers criminels sont partis en fumée
s'il a également que le juge van
ruymbeke avait son bureau dans le cadre
c'est secondaire
là il ya un bâtiment extraordinaire qui
a été brûlé intérêts je crois que
l'oreille savez le papier au web travail
servait déjà en corse et je crois que
c'est pas que c'est pas le plus
important ce code du patrimoine culturel
qui a beaucoup souffert
les pompiers ont réussi tout de même à
sauver le joyau la grande chambre
les oeuvres d'art sont attribués aller à
l'écran l'artiste tout le décor d' de la
grand'chambre souffler les salles
décorées sont ravis et une perte
irrémédiable d'une oeuvre d'art si ce
n'est le l'immeuble l'hiver ironie du
sort l'incendié a permis de découvrir
des décors de papier pas caché dont on
ignorait l'existence
mais dans le coeur de tous les bretons
l'irréparable s'est produit cette nuit
ce palais avait été construit dans la
première moitié du xviie siècle pour
abriter le parlement de bretagne fixé à
rennes sous henri iv
considéré comme l'un des plus beaux
bâtiments de la bretagne dont il
symbolise l histoire ce parlement est l
un des monuments les plus visités de la
région frédéric retard
c'était l'un des monuments les plus
beaux de bretagne avec lui la place
royale constituait un ensemble
architectural hors du commun
le parlement a été construit au début du
xviie siècle sur les plans des
architectes salomon de brosse celui qui
réalisera plus tard le palais du
luxembourg à paris et de germain
gauthier la charpente était un modèle
unique fabriqué par des charpentiers de
saint malo les différentes salles
abritait des peintures et des dorures
inestimable et regorgeait de tapisseries
des gobelins historiquement le parlement
était le symbole de la résistance des
bretons ont pouvoir central en janvier
1789 la bourgeoisie organisé le premier
mouvement de révolte contre les nord
préfigurant la révolution française en
1720 le parlement avait été épargné lors
du grand incendie de rennes ironie du
sort après deux ans de travaux la
rénovation du bâtiment était sur le
point de s'achever avec nous en direct
de rennes le maire de la ville est
membre et bonsoir monsieur le maire
avant de parler un peu plus longuement
des manifestations d'hier à un mode de
de ce drame de cette la disparition de
ce parlement bretagne est-ce que vous
avez des informations sur l'enquêté est
ce que ce sinistre est vraiment à ce
qu'à l'origine de ce feu j ai vraiment
ces fusées détresse comme on l'a dit au
tout début je n'ai pas d'informations
sur l' enquête et nous verrons ce
qu'elle produira simplement je veux dire
que tout comme les rennais je suis très
cruellement frappé attristé par ce qui
vient de se passer
c'est tout un symbole de la bretagne
mais aussi de notre pays puisque la
révolution française a commencé là c'est
le lieu de la justice c'est un lieu de
fierté pour les rennais qui vient de
disparaître et je souhaite que ce lieu
revivent très très rapidement alors
après les très violents affrontements
dont votre ville a été le théâtre hier
vous allez porter plainte contre x car
vous estimez que le maintien de l'ordre
a été uniquement assurée autour de la
préfecture où se trouvait le premier et
le long de son cortège officiel
si je porte plainte contre x
c'est parce que des dégradations ont été
commises alors concernant le maintien de
l'ordre
je suis obligé de constater que l'état
hier n'a pas assurer le maintien de
l'ordre et la sécurité de la ville il a
privilégié la préfecture il a privilégié
le long du cortège officiel mais je
regrette de devoir dire que le centre
ville n'a pas reçu et la présence qu'il
aurait dû recevoir et j'ai vu moi-même
pendant une heure et demie deux mon
bureau la place de la mairie être cassée
parcourue par un certain nombre de
casseurs et sous les yeux des forces de
l'ordre je ne comprends pas cela
alors vous le savez il ya déjà justement
une polémique charles pasqua l'a évoqué
ce matin c'était à l'occasion de la
journée du monde ationale des élus
locaux
le ministre de l'intérieur a
vigoureusement dénoncé vous allez
l'entendre et vous pouvez répondre après
qu'il a vigoureusement dénoncé des
violences qui ont marqué donc cette
manifestation hier à rennes
écoutons mise l'intérieur il ya une
certaine hypocrisie de la part de
certains de ces élus qui après avoir
appelé à manifester et à 7 ans placé en
tête de la manifestation sans avoir à
aucun moment lancé un appel au calme se
plaignent aujourd'hui des conséquences
de ces manifestations à la monsieur
hervé est ce que vous vous sentez visé
par cette attaque du tout et je ne suis
pas homme de polémiques simplement je
veux apporter quelques précisions tout
d'abord n'oublions pas l'essentiel ce
sont les revendications légitimes du
monde de la pêche je pense achement de
la pêche ce soir ils font partie de
notre patrimoine
ce sont des hommes et des femmes qui ont
le droite au respect au nom de la
solidarité
deuxièmement j'étais dans la réunion
présidée par le premier ministre
balladur est co présidée par monsieur
pasqua je m'étonne qu'au cours de cette
réunion à aucun moment le ministre de
l'intérieur nommé fait parvenir des
renseignements sur l'état de ce qui se
passait dans ma ville en tant que maire
j'ai été fondée à recevoir de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur ce genre de
raisonnement et ce genre de
renseignements et puis troisième
observation
je connais un député qui a effectivement
appelé à la manifestation et qui a aussi
financé si j'ai bonne souvenance un car
pour que des élus du pays bigouden
participent à la manifestation ce député
c'est un député du cds monsieur ambroise
guellec
il ne faut pas que l'on polémique sur ce
genre de choses c'est trop sérieux
toutes leurs questions monsieur hervé
est ce que vous avez été étonnés
surprime d'avoir été molesté hier par
certains manifestants
ceci est secondaire je suis un homme
politique
j'assume simplement j'ai vécu des
moments difficiles mais j'assume toutes
mes responsabilités
ceci aurait pu être très grave merci
beaucoup admirent v maire de rennes vous
étiez en direct de votre vie merci on ce
témoignage de retour de cette
manifestation de rennes hier soir
certains manifestants ont saccagé à
nouveau des entrepôts frigorifiques
notamment à nantes ou encore à saint
brieuc ainsi que des magasins de
surgelés près de la rochelle les ports
de dunkerque et de calais ont en
revanche été débloqués en fin de matinée
après l'annoncé hier de nouvelles
mesures en faveur des marins pêcheurs
des mesures qui complètent le premier
plan d'urgence de 300 millions de francs
a annoncé mercredi et ensuite avec la
décision par la commission de bruxelles
de l'instauration provisoire de prix
minimal importations pour certaines
catégories de poissons
les marins pêcheurs ne semble pas décidé
à désarmer ceux de guilvinec eux d'où
est parti le mouvement entend tout cas
décidé de ne pas reprendre la mer lundi
matin nos envoyés spéciaux antoine
cormery et dany boon et sont allés à
l'école de pêche du guilvinec où l'on
n'est d'ailleurs pas très optimiste elle
voit sur l'avenir de la pêche
c'est devenu une tradition au guilvinec
tous les ans début février c'est le
goûter des enfants de marins et comme on
n'est pas en bretagne pour rien
question pâtisserie c'est du top niveau
létalité bretonne des dupes à 4k
seulement voilà cette année le goûter
manqué d'entrain le coeur n'y était pas
les gens sont rentrés hier de rennes
aussi qu'ils ont pas le moral qui auront
obtenu ce qu'ils devaient obtenir alors
bon accompagnement dans cette école de
pêche l'une des plus importantes de
france ils sont une cinquantaine de
jeunes à ceux destinés aux métiers de la
mer pour beaucoup le ca fait approche
les incertitudes aussi banale crise de
la vache folle on commence à se demander
des questions pour la fin de l'école
pour l'examen non autrement on ait le
temps si tu vas aller mieux
si jamais on sort de l'école et puis
quand on puis le bateau pour aller en
mer ou bien sûr trop mais qu'on n'a rien
en signe de solidarité avec leurs aînés
marins pêcheurs les 50 élèves se sont
mises en grève toute cette semaine les
bateaux ne sont pas sorties en mer
eux ne sont pas allés en cours certains
sont même allés manifester à rennes hier
car la chute des cours du poisson les
menace aussi directement un jeune qui
sort de l'école peut espérer avoir du
travail dans l'embauché existe mais la
difficulté c'est le sait le salaire il
va toucher à rodez stib pourquoi entre
trois et cinq mille francs par mois et
autrefois ce salaire était meilleure
avec des cours meilleur lundi matin
johanne jean françois reprendront le
chemin de l'école de pêche au guilvinec
peut-être moins insouciant que ceux qui
les ont précédés
socialistes communistes écologistes et
sympathisants de gauche se retrouve tout
ce week end à paris à l'occasion des
premières assises de la transformation
sociale
but de la manoeuvre renouer le dialogue
trouver des idées nouvelles pour
reconquérir l'opinion après la déroute
électorale de mars dernier reportage
roland sicard jean françois beck pendant
un bon moment
tout le monde s'est demandé pourquoi
dominique voynet hésité à entrer
d'autant qu'à l'intérieur l'ambiance
semblait plutôt bonne socialistes des
communistes de toutes obédiences des
écologistes tout ce petit monde ensemble
du coup michel rocard ou vais être
optimiste
j'attends de tous mouvements que mais
j'espère que les autres en avant de même
chose que toutes les forces disparates
espère changer ce pays en mieux et plus
solidaire se comprennent s'écoute de se
rendre en tout cas dominique voynet est
finalement entré seul en valait la peine
exemple un communiste contestataires et
un communiste orthodoxe qui sont
d'accord c'est plutôt rare c'est vrai
que ça me rappelle un peu ya 25 ans
le début d'un espoir il faut faire un
rassemblement majoritaire sinon on va
subir la droite advitam eternam
c'est une perspective effroyable et
finalement on a cru comprendre pourquoi
et dominique voynet avait attendu c'est
que dominique bonnet préparer quelque
chose c'est elle qui allait faire
entendre
la fausse note de la journée je pense
que les les arrière-pensées de certains
ne sont pas tout à fait pure qu'ils ont
à la fois la main sur le coeur et l'oeil
sur la calendrier électoral mais
personne n'est dupe
alors les choses sont bien claires nous
venons ici pour discuter et nous ne sont
pas prendre en otage par qui que ce soit
tout ne va donc pas encore pour le mieux
dans le meilleur des mondes possibles et
l'important pour le ps c'est que tout le
monde soit là et que michel rocard
apparaissent comme impossible fédérateur
moins d'un an après l'échec historique
des législatives de 93 c'est déjà un
petit exploit
le reste se jugera lors de la
présidentielle et ce sera sans doute une
toute autre paire de manches
invité demain de l'heure de vérité à
midi sur france 2 le nouveau secrétaire
national du parti communiste robert hue
au 9e congrès du front national jean
marie le pen seul candidat a été réélu
cet après-midi par acclamation à la
présidence de ce mouvement à l'appel de
plus de 80 organisations plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont manifesté cet
après-midi pardon dans les rues de paris
contre le racisme et plus précisément
contre les lois sur l'immigration votée
récemment à l'instigation de charles
pasqua reportage eric lemasson doni par
dan
c'est bien connu la musique rassemble
les cultures alors une manifestation
contre le racisme se devait de commencer
par un air de musique
cet après midi à la bastille l'ambiance
était à l'image de leur idée de la
france
jeune joyeuse et surtout multicolores
mais c'est aussi pour militer que douze
à quinze mille personnes s'étaient donné
rendez vous sur le pavé 80 organisations
représentées mais un seul slogan
abrogation des lois dites pasqua loi sur
les conditions de séjour des étrangers
sur la réforme du code de la nationalité
sur les contrôles d'identité
nous pensions que beaucoup de gens
compatissent à ce qui arrive aux
étrangers combattent x et nous pensons
que les français n'ont pas encore jean
pas encore passé de la compassion à la
compréhension des mécanismes civiques et
politiques et sociaux sont à l'origine
de bastia gare de l'est
ils ont marché ils ont chanté c'était
leur première manif
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau
code de la nationalité françois
mitterrand edouard balladur et de très
très nombreuses personnalités politiques
françaises assisteront lundi à
yamoussoukro en côte d'ivoire aux
obsèques solennelles du président
houphouët boigny décédé le 7 décembre à
l'âge de 88 ans en fait les cérémonies
funéraires ont déjà commencé là-bas il y
a trois jours reportage de nous on rit
spéciaux richard biner yanncik elle
fonde en côte ivoire on chante on danse
on rit et puis parfois on pleure
les tambours nantes annoncé le cortège
qui emmènera la dépouille de foued
boigny d'abidjan à yamoussoukro
s'arrêtera yopougon un faubourg
déshérité d'abidjan alors yopougon la
pauvre s'est apprêté pour accueillir son
président car pour les baoulé ou
football y est toujours vivant un chef
éléphant ça ne meurt pas sa samba c'est
tout ne pleurons plus c'est la
séparation nous fêtons ce n'est qu'ils
parlent
le patriarche comme celui là eh bien on
ne peut pas ne pas vider
celui là aucun chasseur pour recoller
d'origine burkinabé et ivoirien
d'adoption il a parcouru 800 km avec son
fusil pour saluer à sa manière son
président je suis arrivé en 52 houphouët
nous a très bien accueillis alors je
suis venu tirer quelques coups de fusil
en son honneur
loin des tam-tams de yopougon abidjan
célèbre aussi celui qui durant 34 ans a
dirigé le pays sous les regards de sa
veuve thérèse et du nouveau président
henri konan bédié
les abidjanais rendant un ultime hommage
à celui qu'ils appelaient
affectueusement le vieux ils étaient
tous pourquoi c'était la moins pire
c'était d'abord un président c'était
d'abord un nombre 10 ha et libellules
nom n'a pas dû voir
le cortège s'ébranle vers la bannière
demeure du président son village natal
devenu capitale yamoussoukro à yopougon
les tam-tams balle toujours
arrivent à faire des choses doit toutes
sirènes hurlantes qui passe ça
s'arrêtait jamais de son vivant le
président verrait se leurrer cela on dit
les anciens
la preuve on m a déjà commencé en son
temps jacques brel avait célébré sur un
air de valse la vache à 1000 francs
maintenant c'est la voiture à 5000
francs depuis hier une aide de 5000
francs et vous savez accordée par l'état
à tout acheteur d'un véhicule neuf en
abandonnant qui abandonne sa voiture de
plus de dix ans à condition qu'elle soit
en état de marche et c'est important
reportage renaud fessaguet et christ au
final ce n'est pas encore la cohue
ni la grande affluence mais la prime de
5000 francs promise par l'état commence
déjà à réveiller un marché passablement
sinistrés depuis hier les halls
d'exposition se remplissent les
premières commandes ce signe bref la
voiture balladur et peut-être l'avenir
de l'automobile tca et terrain plus
c'est certain c'est certain que c'est du
vent on a choqué en plus sur l'occasion
on a une voiture culte d'acier en chaîne
et on en profite il voulait de ces
occasions là pour la changer pour
bénéficier de la prime d'état plusieurs
conditions acheter une voiture neuve
françaises ou étrangères présentes et
une carte grise montre en chf votre
ancien véhicule à plus de dix ans et
surtout prouver qu'il est en état de
marche du travail en perspective pour
les concessionnaires
qu'est-ce qu'on va contrôler bas
qu'elles soient en état de marche tout
simplement qu'on puisse faire le tour du
pâté de maisons sont tombés en panne
avait la voiture a beau être la première
mythologie française la prime d'état ne
suffira pas à décider des hésitants les
constructeurs le savent bien c'est
pourquoi ils proposent tous en plus une
reprise de 3 à 10 mille francs selon les
modèles
une cherono nous
nous aidons nos clients et
par exemple sur une twingo nous offrons
à plus de 3000 francs l'aide de l'état
de 5000 ça fait donc une île
certains modèles comme la clio 5000
bassam el balah d'accord mais après les
gens qui ont les fonds pour payer ces
gens qu'ils ont pris sont le chômage qui
sont victimes ces gens du chômage voir
les comptes a fait sa pièce la joue pas
la prime d'état permettra sans doute de
vendre plusieurs milliers de véhicules
supplémentaires cette année
c'est toujours ça de pris pour une
industrie qui a vu ses ventes chuter de
18% l'an dernier deux motos sport pour
vous signaler tout d'abord qu arnaud
boetsch disputera demain la finale du
tournoi de tennis de marseille face au
tenant du titre le suisse marc rosset
dans le tournoi des cinq nations de
rugby l'équipe du pays de galles
prochaine adversaire du quinze de france
a confirmé sa bonne forme actuelle en
gagnant cette après midi à dublin
autre victoire à l'extérieur les anglais
qui ont battu les écossais au terme d'un
suspense digne d'hitchcock commentaires
laurent frédéric bollée
or
le chant s'appelle flower of scotland et
n'en déplaise à l'anglais andrew qui
bâille tout un peuple est venu communier
et pousser les cosses le seul essai du
match justement écossais signé
wainwright musique triomphante
lorsque se profile la défaite de
l'ennemi séculaire l'angleterre
mais la musique s'arrête quand les
anglais répondent au coup par coup avec
les pénalités de cale hard qui ne rate
rien
12 11 pour l'angleterre à une minute de
la fin du match l'échos tente le tout
pour le tout en scène devient un héros
national
le drop et réussi cette fois c'est sûr
les causes va donc gagné de deux points
mais de nouveaux lecteurs qui se fige
pénalité pour l'angleterre dans les
arrêts de jeu qu'à la rhd encore lui ne
laisse pas passer l'occasion
il est le bourreau des écossais score
final 15 14 mais cos et meurtri la rose
a donc eu raison du chardon dans le même
temps le match irlande galles a sans
doute tenu à cette pénalité riz landaise
quiche sur le poteau
dommage le pays de galles n'en portent
donc 17 à 15 les français sont prévenus
dans quinze jours il se déplace à
cardiff les gallois joueront pour une
troisième victoire consécutive dans le
dernier journal vers minuit catherine
ceylac reviendra bien évidemment sur le
massacre de sarajevo où je vous rappelle
la chute d'un obus sur le principal
marché de la ville a fait au moins 61
morts
un drame qui pour l'instant n'a suscité
dans les capitales occidentales que des
comics et attristé à l'exception du
gouvernement belge qui demandent ce soir
des frappes aériennes sur les batteries
serbe l'impuissance des occidentaux face
au drame de l'ex yougoslavie
il en est beaucoup question dans un film
signé romain goupil sorti mercredi film
intitulé lettre pour elle un coup de
colère pour ne pas dire un coup de
gueule contre la démission de toute une
génération
reportage pascal deschamps bernard puis
sow toi moi qui appartenait à cette
génération qui pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité n'avons
pas souffert ni de la faim ni du froid
ni la justice ni des guerres mais
pourquoi c'était pour ça le marché c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune homme en colère
contre lui même et contre une génération
qui voulait changer le monde
aujourd'hui elle a le pouvoir le monde
n'a pas changé comme des poissons
devenus insensibles à la lumière il
sommes devenus aveugles puis amnésique
on dit il frileux parce qu installer est
content de l'être
alors romain goupil s'interroge caméra à
la main sur les conséquences de cette
passivité et ses pas le mènent bien sûr
dans l'ex-yougoslavie catalyseur de non
acheter je suis encadré par des
responsables fantoche de la police de
vukovar
c'est plus du malais c'est plus du
dégoût c'est de la haine
kova les nationalistes serbes ont obtenu
ici noir total contre les croates
c'était le début de la réalisation de la
grande serbie un exemple parfait d'une
ville désormais ethniquement pur c'était
en 1991
qu'avons nous fait je ne veux pas me
retrouver dans la situation des parents
des grands parents et être l'héritier
d'une génération qui m'a souri nés après
la guerre on ne savait pas maintenant on
sait hélas la grande explication et la
grandeur des fosses de toute la
population sait on ne comprend pas on ne
comprend pas on ne comprend pas ce
conflit alors ils comprennent pas ils
comprennent plus où elle avec votre avis
alors qu'ils y ont été par centaines de
milliers comme touriste arvato coup
c'est les balkans c'est un peuple de
barbares est tout à fait mais cher
romain goupil n'a pas voulu faire oeuvre
d'objectivité il refuse de mettre dos à
dos agresseurs et agressés et si par son
film il rajoute encore des images c'est
pour nous poser une question toute
simple pourquoi nous sommes nous
habituer à toutes celles que nous avons
déjà vu depuis le début de cette guerre
un mot des manifestations de vendredi à
rennes ambroise guellec député cds du
finistère mise en cause tout à l'heure
en direct par edmond hervé le maire de
rennes nous a appelés pour nous faire
savoir qu'il n'avait jamais appelé à
manifester hier à rennes dont acte
dans un instant la météo avec nathalie
rihouet avec encore demain dimanche
beaucoup pluie sur la corse et des
risques d'avalanches sur les massifs
alpins rendez vous demain à 13h
excellente soirée avec surprise surprise
et taratata merci bonsoir